next thing I want to talk about is
stereotyped because we all suffer from
them but we you know in the gay
community we do it to ourselves a lot
because you know you're either a bear or
you're an otter it's a freakin Zoo
nobody knows why it's all about the body
hair yeah you're what do you I'd like to
say I'm an onerous bear an onerous bear
yeah an honor for for the straight
people can explain what an honor is so
younger well bear would be a larger
gentleman of the hairy variety but if
you're a larger general of the hairy
variety and not large this way so much
you can be an honor for a certain period
what other animals are there because oh
there's the bampo Lamia right
Asian bears a panda I heard oh yeah a
pan yeah it's like a petting zoo
it's like a beautiful Robin I can't live
in land with her Lance I thought you
said clams I was like that can wait
thank you I don't think question you say
close your lips you lamb quick glance
conversation is taking a very strange
turn huh all right well let's be so we
need to come up with our own little
animal kingdom so scarf there's no
lesbian proper king I don't know
I never starfish what's that what do I
mean that's really good but it's just
like a girl that lays there like this
headline I'm not a couple male star
exactly for the record is lesbian
bt-dubs Roger is not just the gate so
back to stereotypes but back to
stereotypes so Bri you probably get this
from both sides no pun intended that was
just my own no it's the worst yeah yeah
it's really really hard because a lot of
people are like so when you gonna choose
and I'm like okay I chose like I like
everyone like I'm into all private parts
like I don't like whatever yeah and it's
just like really frustrating cuz like
I've dated people that like guys who are
just like okay so when are you gonna get
this out of your system like do what you
got to do and I'm like okay no it's over
first of all second of all it's like
it's
there's nothing to get out of my system
like this is what's happening all the
time like if you gotta cleanse why just
go away exactly like like Sarabhai
cleanse yeah yeah let's say say we're in
a threesome like and I'm with a guy and
with another girl like I'm just as into
it as the guy is like this is not for
you dude this is for us you know thank
like that's how it is got it so and that
it's not so much more about love than it
is about sex yeah
thank you for it thank you leer that up
what do you guys think there there seems
to be this controversy that girls can be
bi but guys cannot be but you know girls
every girl in college kissing a girl
making out with a girl that's cool
but guys yeah we were talking about this
a little bit earlier yeah is that I feel
like it's more socially palatable and
this is probably due to much of the
media we consume is shot through like a
male lens that a woman would be bisexual
because yeah that's hot because women
are hot and sechs XX um but then if a
man's by it's like well I don't know I
mean I'm not high hahaha you know that
sort of thing but when it comes to like
gay families on television I feel like
it's more consumable more consumer
friendly to see two gay men raising a
family together than it is to see two
lesbians like I think lesbians at this
terrible rap of being not fun-loving
interesting warm people you know and
it's like oh two gay dads that's silly
and sassy and fun yeah plenty of gay men
that aren't silly and sassy and fun I'd
like to consider myself one of these
guys but you could say I think that
that's true if those two gay dads are
raising a daughter
I think things get will go back to that
weird uncomfortable State if those two
gay dads on TV are raising a son you
know why I start I just feel I just feel
like it goes back to challenging that
male heteronormative kind of a catch
okay guys raise a son yes yeah I can't
yeah you know is he gonna turn out gay
automatically I think that but didn't
most of all comedians I know that man to
me got me really that's that question
banan's
will you be disappointed if your child
to go it's already straight he goes
boobs like he will gravitate towards the
breasts in the room
and he's like I'm doing stuff that I
never thought I'd do I go to baseball
games I don't care about baseball okay
first of all but I didn't want my son to
miss out because I'm a big [ __ ] so I
took him to tryouts I'm learning so much
it's tryouts not auditions they're not
costumes they're beautiful in a barn
right and it's not a rehearsal it's
whatever
so but I'm I'm at every game and I could
see the expectation of the other dads
you know like oh what's this kid gonna
do and my kids max it out of the park
cuz he's his own person had nothing to
do I mean he'd be so much better if I
practiced with him you just find a
straight dad yeah everything a strict I
would encourage it but like my my thing
is like the sport is for him to have a
good time and you know get out of the
Sun and be exhausted and not be on the
computer I mean that's what the sport is
for but you see the other dads at the
team like ah like get really get into it
yelling if their kids like focus nice
front and I'm like you know this is
t-ball yeah
I'd understand if this were a ballet
class but people are basically just
putting them in years of therapies
exactly that but it's it's the
expectation on our kids is weird cuz
like I should have been like my dad who
couldn't have been a bigger macho
[ __ ]
breathe I feel like what Hannah said is
so true though like on Modern Family you
have like the silly gay dads but then
you have like a show like the Fosters
which is a great show great show really
really wonderful but then you have and
it's sort of like the serious lesbian
moms and it's like not as fun and yeah
and when why is that they're not happy
they're not one Sahab and one's a vice
principal
you